I believe everybody has the opportunity
to choose what kind of sex they will
have and so it can be sacred but then
there's times I just want to be a dirty
Pig and just go out and do whatever I
want and that's not sacred film in
itself is art but art is also subjective
so for myself I do believe that my work
is on in some level a creative endeavor
which actually does reflect the art
world I mean everything that we do is a
creative endeavor I shoot a lot of
features which means I shoot a lot of
movies that are actually filmed more
like mainstream movies it's basically
the exact same except in the end we have
sex so I said somewhat agree I'm still
new to the industry so I have not really
done a lot of feature films are the big
productions I still do the reality porn
where it's like the piece of guy he
rings the doorbell and then he [ __ ] the
the milf or something so I really see
that as alright in a way but did they
set that pizza guy up a certain way you
have to lean against the doorbell a
certain way you have to hit the lighting
your hair lights back there
[Music]
- one the type of porn that miners will
be able to get is most likely going to
be what's free on the internet and
there's a lot of things missing from the
clips that are free on the internet it's
not very educational it does not teach
them the proper way that sex should be
done consent Lube all of that stuff it's
missing we do a lot of like fantasy
roleplay and different things that like
maybe you would want to do but you can't
actually do in real life and so if a
minor is watching it they don't see what
goes on behind the scenes where the
partners are like communicating with
each other like you can do this for like
this or they don't ski consent happening
on camera porn is it it's a fantasy this
is not reality so a miner watching this
is definitely gonna get the wrong idea
of what real sex is and how it's done
how it started off how you meet a girl
you're not gonna be the pizza man too
many times and it's gonna open up the
piece of this dicks in there that's
sexual harassment folks if they're able
to watch this I think sex would be a lot
more numbing at a lot younger age and we
don't want that as a society like we
still want sex to still be somewhat
seacret to kids I'm gonna say that I
think pornography is a very important
part of learning things and also a minor
is somebody who's under 18 so we're
talking about 17 16 15 they're already
probably watching porn or probably
dealing with that I agree it is not the
place somebody should learn about sex
but if they're doing it how do we make
it so it can be a positive thing I think
they should have like like oh not
softcore but like a wool yarn bite
that's more education
[Music]
three-two-one
I have not shot interracial yet no
matter what they're going to end up
making it so that there's a racist title
like baby goes blacked blacked on
blondes big black [ __ ] on this little
tiny white girl something like that and
I get so much hate on Instagram on
Twitter saying I'm racist saying
whatever and I'm actually the opposite I
don't want to [ __ ] do that
there is a whole site I mean it's one of
the biggest sites in our industry that
is blacked and interracial is
interracial iteration was a white dude
where the Chinese girl interracial is
anything is interracial so for us to
just consider the darkest guy with the
whitest girl I think that's it's just so
stereotype and then they don't even do
that they make sure that the guy is
gigantic Lee huger than the other girl
so it looks intimidating and then I feel
like sometimes why else do you think
that some people are intimidated by
black culture it's really bad like I've
even gotten companies offering me like
hundreds of dollars extra to shew
interracial and it didn't occur to me
until a company started dropping off for
like I was getting all these comments
being like oh my god like you need to
shoot with more black guys and then we
need more BBC and stuff like that people
want that that's the scary that is the
more scary part of this conversation
people actually want racist porn
[Music]
my family day they found out the first
day that my first scene came out my mom
she called me and she was upset and then
like a week after that she was like you
know I love you and like you're still
welcome to come home they're not all for
a day still want me to go back to
college but they had my back I came from
a very bad space as a trans guy and like
you know can try to commit suicide all
kinds of stuff so really I think my
parents are just really happy I'm alive
I'm a hugely successful in the
pornography business so I think what I
did is I taught my parents that this is
a business it is not just dirty nasty
porn in the back alley it's actually a
real lucrative business if you
understand how to create a business from
it
most of my family knows what I do and
like my parents they approve of it
they're like you do what you want you're
an adult but like my extended family my
grandparents my cousins they're all
Mormon they're super religious I've been
blocked on social media I've been like
they don't invite me to a family
reunions anymore just because they're
like you can do what you want but
because our religion views it this way
we're not comfortable with you being
like around our kids and stuff like that
what makes it sad is like it does make
you feel like people forget the person
that you are like it's just a job
like this is just a job for me
[Music]
I have my husband we are open and we're
in a poly relationship and I'm learning
that you know you get what you want and
so if you're not cool with what I do
then you don't get to talk to me my
struggle is um the monogamous part
because if you're with me we have to be
open because I'm going to be out with
other people a lot and I was married and
it got we ended it because he wanted to
be monogamous and he couldn't handle
seeing me go out with other people and
it's like it gets to a point with people
where they're like okay do we want to be
monogamous or are we gonna be open can I
even handle being open like you know I
was engaged to somebody in the industry
and you know it's not easy to find a
person that you have a real connection
with in this industry you know sometimes
porn can destroy you know relationships
and can destroy people we know because I
don't have her anymore
and honestly I don't know if I ever will
you know because sometimes what a dozen
people were immensely can scar you I
didn't want to accept that for what it
was I didn't want to think that porn was
really hurting my relationship we're
really hurting her as much as it was a
time this is just nothing you can do and
you just like I say you live and you
learn there's a lot of things that
happen that people don't understand when
we go to work we are disconnected from
intimacy they people don't know how to
do that in their own life so they don't
believe I think a lot of times they
don't believe us
because a lot of times I'll tell people
you think it's just normal sex I'm like
you know I am angled like this I'm
backwards I'm like mega
the lights getting inside here so you
guys can see what's going on like I'm
not on top of this girl hugging her and
kissing her and making love to her like
that's what I would do at home it is a
completely a job we are disconnected it
is your Europe doing all of this as
emotion and as an actor so I I
personally I think it's a very personal
choice I believe everybody has the
opportunity to choose what kind of sex
they will have how they want to have sex
when they want to have sex why they want
to have sex and so it can be sacred in a
situation where I might feel like I have
a lover and I want to keep it very
personal and I don't want but then
there's times I just want to be a dirty
Pig and just go out and do whatever I
want and that's not sacred
like there's relationship sex that you
actually feel for the person and stuff
and then there's genital sex where you
just want to [ __ ] get off when I was
18 I goes a couple years from 18 to 21
in the industry I was a mess I didn't
know how to separate my personal life
from my porn life I can't be 8 and
Ashley 24/7 and when I first got in the
industry I thought that's who I was I
was ordering my Starbucks coffee and
telling them I was Adin ok like and
that's how I knew that like I needed to
come back and still have my real self
and then be able to turn into Aiden when
I go to set
[Music]
[Applause]
like I'm easy to find I'm on everyday
hey guys my name is Michael thanks so
much for watching this episode if you
liked what you saw subscribe and let us
know a thought in the comments see it